oh [ __ ] did y'all hear Kim Kardashian
got divorced oh what's going on YouTube
I am upset I am upset and everybody on
this [ __ ] run every single
jackass in this world is either tweeting
facebooking Tumtum blurring tumbling
tumble tumble tumble door may you know
the book talked about talking about Kim
Kardashian's divorce man hold up gives a
flying cross argument corn about her
damn divorce everybody is giving this
girl so much damn media attention as if
it was a surprise of the century oh [ __ ]
celebrity got divorce they ain't never
had them before you all act like the
Obamas got divorce or something it was
Kim Kardashian and in the albino
basketball playoff I don't even know his
name
that's how unimportant he is were you
all message me about this big event
saying oh [ __ ] Kim Kardashian got
divorced do you know what the first
thing that popped up in my head was look
she's married I don't give a Toucan Sam
about any celebrities like you know why
because I don't care about them you're
rich [ __ ] what problems do you have
that I should care enough about I'm
gonna coke addiction [ __ ] nobody cares
about your first world problems
y'all tell how angry I'm getting about
my change and how small my hot games
there's children starving somewhere in a
durable country but I gotta watch a
reality TV problem about your marital
issues you why the hell do we care so
much about a celebrity's life
hey Dawg you heard Johnny Depp got a new
puppy dog man you ain't your puppy son
Oh see it y'all hear that Justin Bieber
got a new haircut you and your lesbian
haircut everybody is acting like this is
the greatest [ __ ] news of the last
couple centuries did you know that a man
can walk down the moon once but that's
not interesting all
oh [ __ ] the Kim Kardashian got a big
offer we have cars running on corn oil
and sunlight but wash [ __ ] up Kim
Kardashian goddess before such a big
brand huffing news what the hell oh but
it's not a fall she gets all the media
attention leave her alone I don't give a
[ __ ] if you want to go ahead and plead
for her case then go make your own vlog
[ __ ] thousands of people are getting
divorced in America every day she is not
special I am still trying to figure out
what she has done in her life for us to
even call her a celebrity let me Google
this [ __ ] up she had Ray J's look in the
mouth and her daddy say oj that's it
people blow up a good piece of news on
social media help out the human race I
don't know do something with yourself
besides tweet about Kim Kardashian I am
sick of shitty ass social media being
blown up over garbage don't blow up
garbage people
I'm time to [ __ ] this isn't garbage
though this isn't garbage you could look
son Kim Kardashian I don't know you I
don't know anything about you I don't
know you on a personal basis and you
know what i'ma tell you something girl
and this is for all you women out there
looks Fame Kim you're gonna be one
shrimpy an old lady one day with your
big old booty sagging and all you got
left is your sorry-ass personality and I
feel sorry for you
me personally when you gonna say I'm
ugly uh well well I guess you got me on
me you know what I'm done with this [ __ ]
I'm done I'm part of social media and
huh and I feel ashamed I'm done I'm
quitting YouTube I'm sorry you do this
is my last video visit actually I'm not
I got bills to pay so uh I can't but you
know what me if later on tonight I ask
you to be my girlfriend
right right you know what
Oh
this person didn't ask me to blow up
their YouTube or anything like that
but I'm gonna do it anyways check it out
on my youtube channel page you will go
to the bottom of my friends list and you
will see something that says go inspired
go calm either check out the website or
click on the YouTube channel for you to
check out people helping other people
and for what reason
nothing just to help other people out
check out those videos and see something
inspiring for once and spread those
videos out Oh what the grasshopper Kim
Kardashian's other people are such a big
news